welcome to the newshour russia and
ukraine have signed a deal to reopen
ukrainian ports on the black sea for
grain exports raising hopes of easing
the global food crisis the ceremony in
istanbul was overseen by the u.n
secretary general and the turkish
president who brokered the agreement
grain shipments have been stuck in
ukraine since the start of the russian
invasion in february and that's led to a
rise in global food prices
this is an agreement for the world it
will bring relief for developing
countries on the edge of bankruptcy and
the most vulnerable people on the edge
of famine
and it will help stabilize global food
prices which were already at record
levels even before the war a true
nightmare for developing countries
specifically the initiative we just
signed opens a pass
for significant volumes of commercial
food exports from three key ukrainian
ports in the black sea odessa
chevonnorsk and yuzny
istanbul
this joint step we are taking in
istanbul together with russia and
ukraine will be a new turning point that
will revive the hopes for peace this is
my sincere hope whatever direction the
developments on the field will take the
war will finally end on the negotiating
table this friendly and peaceful
atmosphere that we have established will
be to the benefit of humanity
and this will transform into steps aimed
at ending the war
now in a few moments we'll be speaking
to our diplomatic editor james baze
who's at the united nations in new york
but first let's get reaction out of
ukraine with alan fisher who's in keeve
and of course we will get him shortly we
have slight technical problem there
let's cross over to uh james bayes who's
our diplomatic editor uh in new york and
we'll get to um shortly jane so let's
just begin with the fact that
what's happened it has been very quick
in the last what hour or so
markets normally react very quickly and
i know you're our diplomatic editor but
can you be our economic editor too and
just tell us how they reacted as quickly
as we might have imagined where you are
in new york
i'm afraid so i don't have i have
knowledge of the markets i've just come
out of a diplomatic briefing uh but
certainly the briefing i had was with
the uh the us ambassador who is in
charge of sanctions and part of this
deal is trying to get russian grain and
fertilizer this is the the bit that
favors russia get russian grain and
fertilizer back on global markets
because he's making the point that they
were never subject to sanctions and that
no one should have been stopping the
flow of those now he also told me that
he believes that with regard to shipping
companies and to insurance companies
they should see no problem now in now
that there is this deal and that they
should be able to comply with this deal
and not be wary but of course they are
going to be wary because this deal
involves ships traveling through mined
waters
we're told through channels that have
been clearly identified so i think that
is one of the tests of this how the
shipping market how the insurance market
reacts
and i think there will be a test of
implementation in the coming weeks to
see if this goes ahead it's not going to
happen straight away you're not going to
see a ship that is sailing uh in the
next uh in the next couple of uh
days i think we're talking a couple of
weeks at the earliest for the first ship
of grain and remember that we're talking
about 22 million tons of grain backlog
that has formed in ukraine and caused
much of the global food crisis it's
going to take some time to get all of
that grain out uh experts estimate
probably about four months uh to get all
of that grain out to global markets so
if you thought that it was gonna
alleviate the global food crisis this is
a major breakthrough but nothing's gonna
happen overnight here james you've been
talking behind the scenes to diplomats
for many weeks now about this conflict
uh in ukraine how delicate have the
negotiations been to get to this phase
because we know that from actually
signing an agreement in istanbul
over the next few weeks until they can
get those first ships out as you say
with grain on them anything can happen
oh absolutely it remains a very delicate
situation and it has been throughout i
can tell you that they were talking
about this signing ceremony weeks ago
the first time i heard a potential date
for it uh taking place
and it's been pushed back and pushed
back lots of meetings i think one of the
final meetings took place earlier this
week and that's when president erdogan
of turkey who along with the un has been
the main
broker of this deal met with president
putin they were having a summit with the
iranian president in tehran on the
sidelines of that they had a meeting
that was an important meeting i think
some will be asking the important
question why has russia agreed to this
deal now
what is russia's view on this and does
this suggest in any way that russia is
changing its overall calculations with
regard to the ukrainian war uh certainly
uh the diplomats that i've canvassed on
this believe that russia is getting too
much flack for the global food crisis
and believes that it should be on the
right side of the argument there but
most of them do not believe and even the
secretary general i asked him this a
week ago uh in an open press briefing
they don't believe this is necessarily
now going to translate to peace in
ukraine this is a very specific but very
important deal but unlikely to affect
the ongoing war in the country james
bay's our diplomatic editor thanks james
for the update let's cross over to alan
fishner who we can actually uh get in
touch with now in key valon uh as james
said a very delicate situation that is
only specific the agreement that's been
signed today to grain shipments i mean
the ukrainians themselves have made it
very clear haven't they to this point
that they're not dealing signing a deal
with russia they're signing a deal with
the un
end of
you have the the secretary general and
he's talking in optimistic terms saying
this is growing for optimism
suggesting that somehow this could lead
to more talks that's not something that
the ukrainians are looking at as far as
they're concerned this is one and done
for the time being they see this as a
deal that they have signed with the
united nations and with turkey and
certainly not with russia and we heard
from a senior adviser to the
presidential office on twitter just in
the last couple of hours saying look
it's very clear there will be no russian
vessels in ukrainian territorial waters
under this deal the ukrainians here are
very clear that they see the the
russians as an aggressor nation and we
know that they're approaching the icc
the international criminal court to set
up a whole new investigation with the
intention of charging senior russian
leadership with the
crime of being an aggressor nation they
also say there will be no russian
inspectors in any of the three ukrainian
ports that are under their control if
there to be any searches of ships that
won't happen in ukrainian waters that
will happen in turkish territorial
waters so they are making this
absolutely clear look we have signed
this deal but we will respond to any
provocation from the russians with
military action immediately on late
thursday here in kiev diplomats were
saying look this isn't a done deal yet
even though the united nations and
turkey were saying the wording has been
agreed president zelinski hinted that
there was agreement when he made his
usual address late on thursday night by
saying there was going to be an
agreement in turkey that would help the
country and so they're not seeing this
as a pathway to peace talks not least
because in the last 24 hours or so
sergey lavrov the russian foreign
minister has said that the russian
territorial intention is not just the
donbass region but they see extending it
to kharkiv and also japarisia which is
much more than they had said and and
president zelinski has said that they
intend to inflict a great deal of damage
to the russians in the coming weeks so
there may be optimism that they've
managed to get the two sides to sign an
agreement not with each other but with
third parties but the prospect of this
leading to some sort of agreement in the
near future that will end the war well
that's simply not going to happen ellen
fisher in keith thanks very much